It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees, Google FiWireless is not subject to data traffic
现在正值盛花期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这绝对是一个不会常有的超值优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。除税费和政府规费外，Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会受到数据流量
deprioritization during times of high network usage. psychology is taking a winter break. So we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. Last year, I talked to psychologist Carrie Lieberwitz about how to embrace winter, how cold weather and darkness affect our body and mind, and why we should lean into the coziness of the season. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in early January. Thank you for listening. Are you dreading the cold months ahead? With fewer hours of daylight, bare trees, and slush, snow, and freezing rain in the forecast,
降速的影响。心理学正在度寒假。因此我们正在重播过去的一些最爱单集。去年，我与心理学家卡丽·利伯维茨 (Carrie Lieberwitz) 谈论了如何拥抱冬天、寒冷天气和黑暗如何影响我们的身心，以及为什么我们应该顺应季节的舒适感。我们希望您喜欢这档来自资料库的单集节目。说到心理学，我们将在一月上旬带着新单集回归。感谢您的收听。您是否在恐惧即将到来的寒冷月份？随着白天时间缩短、树木光秃，再加上预报中的雨夹雪、雪和冻雨，
winter often seems like a season to be endured rather than celebrated. But in Scandinavia, where the winters are among the coldest and darkest on earth, many people look forward to winter as a time of coziness, beauty, and rest. So what can we learn from the way that Scandinavians approach the season? How can our mindset, the way we think about winter, change how we experience it? How do cold weather and darkness affect our body and mind? And how might we work with the changing seasons rather than against them to appreciate what winter has to offer? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
冬天往往看起来是一个需要忍受而不是庆祝的季节。但在北欧的斯堪的纳维亚，那里的冬天是地球上最寒冷、最黑暗的时期之一，许多人却将冬天期盼为舒适、美丽和休息的时刻。那么，我们可以从斯堪的纳维亚人对待这个季节的方式中学到什么？我们的心态，即我们对冬天的看法，如何改变我们的体验？寒冷的天气和黑暗如何影响我们的身心？我们又该如何顺应季节的变化，而不是与它们对抗，从而欣赏冬天所能提供的一切？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Carrie Liebuwitz, a health psychologist, speaker and writer who studies the power of mindsets to improve our health and well-being. In 2014, she spent a year in Tromsome, Norway, above the Arctic Circle, to study how people experience winter there. In her new book, How to Winter, harness your mindset to thrive on cold, dark, or difficult days. She discusses how psychological science and lessons from Norway and other cold-weather countries can help us find more contentment and happiness in the season. Dr. Liebuwitz, thank you for joining me today. So happy to be here. Thanks for having me.
我是金·米尔斯 (Kim Mills)。我今天的嘉宾是卡丽·利伯维茨 (Dr. Carrie Liebuwitz) 博士，她是一位健康心理学家、演讲者和作家，专门研究心态改善健康和福祉的力量。2014年，她在北极圈以北、挪威特罗姆瑟度过了一年，研究那里的人们如何体验冬天。在她的新书中《如何过冬：驾驭你的心态，在寒冷、黑暗或艰难的日子里蓬勃发展》（How to Winter, harness your mindset to thrive on cold, dark, or difficult days），她探讨了心理科学以及来自挪威和其他寒冷天气国家的经验教训如何帮助我们在这个季节找到更多的满足感和幸福感。利伯维茨博士，非常感谢您今天能来。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我。
I'd like to start by asking about Tromso. Much of your research on winter mindset springs from the year you spent there back in 2014. Can you tell us what's winter like in Tromso? What's the weather like? How much daylight to the yet? And how do people feel about winter there? So Tromsa is a really unique place. It's over 200 miles north of the Arctic Circle.
我想从关于特罗姆瑟的问题开始。你关于冬季心态的大部分研究都源于你在 2014 年在那里度过的那一年。你能告诉我们特罗姆瑟的冬天是什么样的吗？天气怎么样？有多少日照？那里的人们对冬天有什么感觉？所以特罗姆瑟是一个非常独特的地方。它位于北极圈以北 200 多英里处。
It's a small island of about 70,000 inhabitants. And because it's so far north, they have really extreme changes in daylight between the seasons. So in the summer, they have two months of what's called the midnight sun where the sun never sets. And in the winter, they have the opposite. So what's called the polar night. So in Tromsa, the sun sets on November 21st and doesn't rise again for two months until. January 21st. Now, when a lot of people hear this, they think full darkness, full night time. That does happen farther north, but Tromsa has what's called civil twilight. So that's the time when the
这是一个拥有约 7万居民的小岛。由于它地处极北，不同季节的日照时间会发生极其剧烈的变化。所以在夏天，他们有长达两个月的“午夜太阳”，太阳从不落山。而在冬天，情况则相反，也就是所谓的“极夜”。所以在特罗姆瑟，太阳在 11 月 21 日落下，并且有两个月不会升起，直到 1 月 21 日。现在，当许多人听到这个消息时，他们会认为是一片漆黑、完全的夜晚。更靠北的地方确实会这样，但特罗姆瑟有所谓的“民用曙暮光”。也就是
sun is just below the horizon. So, you know, the way the sky gets light before the sun officially rises or stays light after it sets, you get that for anywhere from sort of two to five or six hours a day during the polar night. And that light can be very beautiful. It's very soft. It's not direct. You can have, if it's a clear day, these amazing sunrise and sunset colors. It also makes the world very blue. A lot of people like to refer to the polar night as the blue time. It's the time of year where the world is very blue tinted. And Tromsa also has a unique climate because it's located on the Gulf Stream. So even though it's so far north, it's actually a lot warmer than you might expect. So the average winter temperatures are usually in the 20s Fahrenheit, which is cold,
太阳刚好在地平线以下的时期。所以，你知道，太阳正式升起前天空变亮的方式，或者太阳落山后天空保持明亮的现象，在极夜期间，你每天大约可以持续两到五个小时或六个小时。这种光线可以非常美丽。它非常柔和。它不是直射的。如果是一个晴朗的日子，你就能看到这些令人惊叹的日出和日落色彩。它还使世界变得非常蔚蓝。许多人喜欢把极夜称为“蓝色时光”。一年中的这个时候，世界带有非常浓重的蓝色调。特罗姆瑟还拥有独特的气候，因为它位于墨西哥湾暖流沿岸。因此，尽管它地处极北，但实际上比你预期的要暖和得多。所以冬季平均气温通常在华氏 20 度左右，也就是很冷，
below freezing. It's very snowy. But considering that it's 200 miles north of the Arctic Circle, it's not as cold as most people expect. And if you go inland away from the coast, it gets much, much colder relatively quickly. So it has these really interesting winter conditions where it's definitely snowy, definitely cold, definitely wintry, but also the darkness is a big thing, that the polar night is really one of the things that makes tromso the most extreme in terms of climate. And people there have varying opinions about the winter. Of course, there are people like everywhere who struggle with that time of year, who struggle with a lack of vitamin D, or they have a hard time getting up in the morning. But there's a lot of people who really appreciate the
低于冰点。雪下得很大。但考虑到它位于北极圈以北 200 英里处，它并没有大多数人想象的那么冷。如果你向内陆走，远离海岸，气温会相对较快地变得非常非常寒冷。因此，它有着这些非常有趣的冬季条件，这里绝对下雪、绝对寒冷、绝对充满冬日气息，但黑暗也是一个大问题，极夜确实是让特罗姆瑟的气候变得最为极端的因素之一。那里的人们对冬天的看法也各不相同。当然，和任何地方一样，有些人很难熬过那段时间，他们难以应对缺乏维生素 D 的问题，或者早上很难起床。但也有很多人非常欣赏
polar night and who find it to be extremely magical, extremely peaceful, cozy, and really see it as a very special and beautiful time of year. And that was something that, you know, before I moved there, I was imagining this sort of darkness, foreboding, scary. And I was surprised by how gentle and gorgeous it was without the sun. Now, you say in your book that you were not a big fan of winter before you move there. So were you worried about how you would handle the cold and all that darkness? I was. I mean, other researchers out there may be familiar with this experience.
极夜，并发现它极其神奇、极其平和、舒适，真正将它视为一年中非常特殊和美丽的一段时光。在我搬到那里之前，我一直在想象这种黑暗、不祥、可怕。而当我真正看到没有太阳时它是多么温和和华丽，我感到很惊讶。现在，你在书中说，在搬到那里之前，你并不是冬天的超级粉丝？那么，你当时是否担心自己如何应对寒冷和所有的黑暗？我是的。我的意思是，其他研究人员可能对这种经历并不陌生。
You know, you apply for a bunch of research grants. Most of them you don't get. And so you're not really intending to actually follow through with all of them. And so I had put out a bunch of them. bunch of sort of fellowship applications to go abroad. And then I got this one to go move to the Arctic for a year. And I was like, oh my God, what have I done? Like, am I really going to move to this place? You know, I grew up on the Jersey Shore south of New York City in a town where summer was king and we sort of lived for the summers and the beach time. And I did not enjoy the
你知道，你申请了一堆研究经费。其中大多数你都拿不到。所以你并不是真的打算把它们全都付诸实践。所以我当时投递了很多申请。投递了一堆出国做访问学者的申请。然后我得到了去北极生活一年的机会，当时我就想，天哪，我都做了些什么？我是真的要搬到这个地方去吗？你知道，我在纽约市以南的泽西海岸长大，那里的夏天为王，我们几乎是为了夏天和海滩时光而活着。而且我不喜欢
winter. I really didn't and still don't really enjoy the feeling of being cold. I really really struggled with winter mornings growing up, especially in high school. And I was really unsure what it would be like to live through such an extreme winter. And the people I talked to when I told them I was moving to this city in the Arctic, especially in the U.S., people had really strong reactions. People would say things like, I could never do that. I would be so depressed. Like, don't you think you're going to get depressed? And so both my own internal narrative and also the cultural narrative around me was that this was going to be an extremely challenging and a harsh environment on something I was really going to have to try my best just to endure and make it
冬天。我真的不喜欢，而且现在也仍然不太喜欢寒冷的感觉。我成长过程中，尤其是在高中时，真的非常非常难熬过冬天的早晨。我真的不确定在如此极端的冬天生活会是什么样子。当我告诉人们我要搬到北极的这座城市时，特别是美国人，他们的反应非常强烈。人们会说这样的话：“我绝对做不到。我会抑郁死的。难道你不觉得自己会得抑郁症吗？”因此，无论是我内心的独白，还是我周围的文化叙事，都认为这将是一个极具挑战性和严酷的环境，我必须尽最大努力去忍受并熬过
through. But it didn't turn out that way. No, that wasn't really the story I encountered in Norway. I mean, you know, and I think this really speaks to the value of doing cultural research and spending time on the ground in these places, right? Because, you know, in the end, the research study I did there was a survey and now you can do online surveys from anywhere. But so much of my research was informed by living in this place and talking to the people there and talking to people about what winter was going to be like, what I should be looking at, what I should be thinking about. And I was just finding that people in Tronso had a really different relationship to the winter than I had growing up in New Jersey,
它。但事情并非如此。不，这并不是我在挪威真正遇到的故事。我的意思是，你知道，我认为这真正说明了做文化研究和在这些地方实地花时间的价值，对吧？因为，你知道，最终，我在那里做的研究是一项调查，现在你可以在任何地方进行在线调查。但我的很多研究都是通过在那个地方生活、与那里的人们交谈、跟人们讨论冬天会是什么样子、我应该关注什么、我应该思考什么而形成的。我只是发现特罗姆瑟的人们与我在新泽西长大时对冬天的关系完全不同，
despite the winter being longer, darker, darker, colder, harsher in many respects, people there talked about the things they were looking forward to. They looked forward to skiing and coziness and the beauty of the polar night and the film festival that happens in the dark time in January and all of these things that they weren't focused on all of the things to come that would be annoying or uncomfortable or unpleasant, they were really oriented towards the opportunities of the season and the things that made the season special that they were looking forward to.
尽管特罗姆瑟的冬天在许多方面更漫长、更黑暗、更寒冷、更严酷，但那里的人们谈论的都是他们所期待的事情。他们期盼滑雪、舒适感、极夜的美丽、在一月份黑暗时期举办的电影节，以及所有这些事情，他们并没有专注于即将到来的所有烦人、不舒服或令人不快的事情，而是真正面向这个季节的机遇，以及让这个季节变得特别、他们所期待的事情。
Now, the subtitle of your book is harness your mindset to thrive on cold, dark, or difficult days. And before we talk about a winter mindset, could you define more broadly, what is a mindset? Why is it important? Sure. So I completed my PhD in psychology at Stanford University working in the Stanford Minded Body Lab with Professor Alia Krum. And this follows the tradition of Dr. Carol Dweck and her work on growth in fixed mindsets about intelligence. And so the definition I use really comes from Dr. Alia Crum and the Stanford Minded Body Lab, which is that we think of mindsets as a core assumption or belief about something in the world. how it works. So they tend to be very basic and very broad, right? Intelligence is fixed or intelligence is malleable. Stress is enhancing for performance and well-being or debilitating for performance and well-being. Winter is wonderful or winter is dreadful. Winter is full of opportunity or winter is limiting. And a lot of the time we have these mindsets and they might be influencing us, but we're not
现在，你的书的副标题是“驾驭你的心态，在寒冷、黑暗或艰难的日子里蓬勃发展”。在我们谈论冬季心态之前，你能更广泛地定义一下，什么是心态？为什么它很重要？当然。我在斯坦福大学获得了心理学博士学位，师从斯坦福身心实验室的阿利亚·克鲁姆（Alia Crum）教授。这延续了卡罗尔·德维克（Carol Dweck）博士及其关于智力的成长型和固定型心态的研究传统。因此，我使用的定义实际上来自阿利亚·克鲁姆博士和斯坦福身心实验室，即我们将心态视为关于世间某事及其工作原理的核心假设或信念。因此，它们往往非常基础且非常广泛，对吧？智力是固定的，或者智力是可塑的。压力对表现和健康是有益的，还是对表现和健康有害的。冬天是美好的，或者冬天是可怕的。冬天充满机遇，或者冬天是局限的。很多时候，我们拥有这些心态，它们可能正在影响我们，但我们并不
always aware of these sort of really broad assumptions that we have about these very basic things in the world. If a person wants to change their attitude toward winter, then how do they change their winter mindset? Where do you start? Well, I think you start by recognizing that you have a winter mindset, right? You know, we all go through winter and we have ideas about winter. We have these mindsets. We have schemas. We have expectations. We have all these associations. We have all these associations that come up with the season and recognizing that those in and of themselves are powerful and that those are influencing our experience. So taking stock of your mindset, noticing it, trying to think about what comes up for you when you think about winter,
总是意识到我们对世间这些非常基本的事物所持有的这种非常广泛的假设。如果一个人想要改变对冬天的态度，那么他们该如何改变自己的冬季心态？你从哪里开始呢？嗯，我认为你首先要认识到自己拥有冬季心态，对吧？你知道，我们都经历过冬天，我们对冬天有看法。我们拥有这些心态。我们有图式。我们有期望。我们有所有这些联想。我们有所有这些与这个季节相关的联想，并认识到这些本身就很强大，并且它们正在影响我们的体验。因此，审视你的心态，注意到它，试着去思考当你想到冬天时，什么会浮现在你的脑海中，
when you envision going into the season is really important. And then I think there's lots of different strategies that we can do for changing our mindset. So we can do things like deliberately focus our attention, right? So mindsets are. So mindsets are, are they're biased. You know, the truth is that winter, like lots of things, is complex. There's parts of winter that are dreadful and annoying and uncomfortable. And there are parts that are special and beautiful and wonderful. That's true of any season.
当你展望即将到来的季节时，这是非常重要的。然后我认为我们可以采取许多不同的策略来改变我们的心态。所以我们可以做一些事情，比如刻意集中我们的注意力，对吧？所以心态是。所以心态是，是有偏见的。事实是，冬天和许多事情一样，是复杂的。冬天有些部分是可怕的、烦人的和不舒服的。也有一些部分是特殊的、美丽的和美好的。任何季节都是如此。
That's true of almost anything that we encounter in the world. But what we attend to more influences what we feel about the winter, influences our motivation and how we behave with the winter. And so we can start consciously nudging our attention towards noticing the things that we do like, right? So if you wake up and it's a cold, wet, rainy day, are you going to immediately jump into noticing and thinking about how this is going to make your commute more difficult or how you don't want to go outside and walk your dog in this weather? Or are you going to jump into how this is the perfect weather for putting on your favorite sweater, for getting a mug of something hot, for doing work inside in front of a computer or reading a book or whatever it is. And your experience of that day and that weather is going to be really different depending on what you attend to.
我们在世间遇到的几乎所有事情都是如此。但是，我们更多地关注什么，就会影响我们对冬天的感受，影响我们的动力以及我们对冬天的行为方式。因此，我们可以开始有意识地引导我们的注意力去注意到我们确实喜欢的事情，对吧？所以如果你醒来，这是一个寒冷、潮湿、下雨的日子，你是会立刻把注意力集中并思考这会如何让你的通勤变得更加困难，或者你如何不想出门在这种天气里遛狗？还是你会开始考虑这正是穿上你最喜欢的毛衣、喝一杯热饮、坐在电脑前在室内工作或读书的完美天气？你对那天和那种气味的体验将根据你关注的重点而大不相同。
We can also leverage other strategies in our behaviors like we can cultivate winter rituals to give ourselves things to look forward to in the season. We can leverage social support so we can lean on our friends and family for cozy indoor activities, but also to help us get outside in the winter. when maybe it doesn't come as easily. So a lot of these broad motivational strategies that we use in psychology to help us do anything we want to do to achieve our goals can help us change our mindset about winter and see the season a bit differently. In the book, you advise people to get outside during the winter, even though you may
我们还可以在行为中利用其他策略，比如我们可以培养冬季仪式，为自己在这个季节里寻找期待的事物。我们可以利用社会支持，这样我们可以依靠我们的朋友和家人来进行舒适的室内活动，同时也可以帮助我们在冬天走出户外。当这可能不那么容易做到的时候。因此，我们在心理学中用来帮助我们做任何我们想做的事情以实现目标的许多广泛的动机策略，都可以帮助我们改变对冬天的心态，并以稍微不同的视角看待这个季节。在书中，你建议人们在冬天走到户外，尽管你可能
think that it's cold and it's going to be unpleasant. Why is getting outside so important? This is something I really observed all throughout Scandinavia, certainly when I lived in Trumso and also when I traveled elsewhere from my book, that being outside in the winter is really important to embracing the season. And I think there's a couple of reasons why this is. One is that we know that connection with nature, movement, and fresh air are all natural antidepressants. So if you feel a little bit down in the winter going outside, and moving your body just a little bit even is going to be an antidote to some of those feelings
会认为外面很冷而且会很不舒服。为什么走到户外如此重要？这是我在整个斯堪的纳维亚半岛都观察到的一点，当我住在特罗姆瑟时当然如此，当我为写书去其他地方旅行时也是如此，在冬天走到户外对于拥抱这个季节非常重要。我认为有几个原因可以解释这一点。首先，我们知道与大自然的联系、运动和新鲜空气都是天然的抗抑郁药。因此，如果你在冬天感到有点沮丧，走出去，
and is going to really change your mood. We know that walking even for a little bit or connecting with nature for a little bit provides a mood boost and an emotional boost. I also think that when we think about winter mindset broadly, really it boils down to whether we see the season as one of limitations or one full of opportunity. And I think when we think about winter limiting us, we so often focus on the things that we can't do or that we feel that we can't do in the winter.
哪怕只是稍微活动一下身体，也将是其中一些负面情绪的解药，并会真正改变你的心情。我们知道，哪怕只是散步一小会儿或与大自然短暂接触，也能提升心情和情绪。我也认为，当我们广泛地思考冬季心态时，它实际上归结于我们是将这个季节视为充满局限性的季节，还是充满机遇的季节。我认为，当我们认为冬天限制了我们时，我们常常关注我们在冬天不能做的事情，或者我们觉得自己做不到的事情。
And a lot of those involve going outside and enjoying the outdoors. And so when we practice bundling up for the elements, wearing our layers, putting on waterproof, raincoats and boots and things, and going outside, we can begin to see that it is possible to go outside and enjoy ourselves in. winter weather. And not only does this overturn some of our narratives about the limitations of the season, it also makes other things easier, right? Like when your friends invite you to go lean up somewhere, but in order to do that, you have to go outside and brave the cold, that becomes a barrier to doing things. So the more that you practice getting outside and dressing up and being in the elements, the less that becomes a barrier to doing other things that might be good for your health and well-being in the winter, whether that's going to the gym or meeting up with friends
其中许多都涉及走到户外并享受大自然。因此，当我们练习为应对恶劣天气而裹紧衣服、穿上层叠衣物、穿上防水雨衣、靴子等并走到户外时，我们就可以开始明白，在冬季天气里走到户外并享受乐趣是完全可能的。这不仅颠覆了我们对该季节局限性的一些看法，还让其他事情变得更容易，对吧？比如，当你的朋友邀请你在某处聚会时，但要做到这一点，你必须走到户外勇敢面对寒冷，这就会成为做事的一个障碍。因此，你越是练习走到户外、盛装打扮并身处恶劣天气中，这成为你在冬天做其他对健康和福祉有益的事情的障碍就会越少，无论是去健身房还是与朋友见面
or going out to movies and museums and things that are particularly well-suited to indoor winter time, but you still have to go outside and leave your house to get there. And I think that that is a really powerful lesson. This is actually something that I assign my students to do in the workshops that I give and in the classes that I teach about winter mindset is I assign them to bundle up the Scandinavians have a saying there's no such thing as bad weather, only bad clothing, and go outside for a winter excursion. And then they have to write a reflection about it. And so often it's people being like, I didn't want to do this. I was thinking of any excuse to bail. I go outside. I'm so uncomfortable. And then they're outside five, 10, 15 minutes. They're moving their body.
或者去看电影和参观博物馆，这些都特别适合室内冬季时光，但你仍然必须走到户外并离开家才能到达那里。我认为这是一个非常强有力的教训。这实际上是我在讲授的冬季心态工作坊和教授的课程中分配给学生的一项任务，我要求他们像斯堪的纳维亚人那样穿好衣服——斯堪的纳维亚人有一句谚语：没有糟糕的天气，只有糟糕的衣服——并进行一次冬季远足。然后他们必须写一篇反思。通常情况下，人们会说：“我不想这么做。我能想出任何借口来临阵脱逃。我走到了外面。我感到非常不舒服。”然后他们在外面待了五分钟、十分钟、十五分钟。他们在活动身体。
They're walking. They're noticing there's all this beauty around them. Actually, They're not as cold as they were when they first stepped outdoors. Their body's heating up. Their mood is lifting. And I can't tell you how many people who said that they didn't want to do this assignment end up then having repeat outdoor winter excursions after being assigned to go outdoors in the winter. And so it's something you really have to try yourself to, I think, fully embody the impact that it has. You studied people in Tromso.
他们在散步。他们注意到周围有这么多美景。实际上，他们并没有刚踏出户外时那么冷了。他们的身体在变热。他们的心情在好转。我无法告诉你，有多少人曾说他们不想做这项作业，但在被指派冬天去户外之后，最终却开始重复进行户外冬季远足。因此，我认为，为了真正体悟它所产生的影响，你必须亲自尝试一下。你研究了特罗姆瑟的人们。
And, I mean, they grew up there. So this is what's normal to them. So wouldn't you think that they would have? have learned how to cope? I mean, did you find a lot of people who really didn't or people who didn't like winter? Did they just leave that part of Norway? Yeah. So I think people there struggle with aspects of the season. I think some people feel the effects on their energy, have a hard time getting up. You know, we know that light and dark influences our circadian rhythms. And certainly I also struggle waking up in the morning when it's darker in the winter.
我的意思是，他们在那里长大。所以这对他们来说是正常的。那你难道不认为他们已经学会了如何应对吗？我的意思是，你有没有发现很多人其实并不适应，或者不喜欢冬天的人？他们难道不只是离开那部分的挪威吗？是的。所以我觉得那里的人们也在努力应对这个季节的某些方面。我认为有些人感受到了它对精力的影响，很难起床。你知道，我们知道光线和黑暗会影响我们的昼夜节律。当然，当冬天变黑时，我在早晨醒来时也很挣扎。
And so there are people there who do have a hard time. If you really hate it, I think you would move somewhere else. Although, you know, even if you move to southern Norway to Oslo, it's still pretty dark. So unless you're going to leave the country entirely, it's hard to get away from winter in Norway. And I think that that is part of it. It's like you said, you know, they grow up there. They learn how to behave in the winter. And they almost have no choice but to adapt. I think it's actually when you live somewhere where the winter is more extreme, where the darkness is more extreme, it's obvious that you have to change your behavior to adapt to winter. It's obvious that maybe you would slow down and sleep more and rest more in the dark season and be more active and doing even more things outside in the midnight sun in the summer. It's obvious that you have to change your wardrobe and how you dress. It's obvious that you have to change the way you light your house. And so they develop these behaviors that I think are extremely helpful in embracing the season in working with the season because they're doing things differently in the winter. I think those of us who live at more middle latitudes don't have that same urgent need to change our behavior. We sort of dilute ourselves into thinking, oh yeah, I can have the same schedule year round.
所以在那里确实有人过得很艰难。如果你真的很讨厌它，我想你会搬到别的地方去。不过，你知道，即使你搬到挪威南部的奥斯陆，天黑得也挺早。所以除非你完全离开这个国家，否则很难在挪威摆脱冬天。我认为这也是其中的一部分。就像你说的，你知道，他们在那里长大。他们学会了如何在冬天行事。他们几乎别无选择，只能适应。我认为，实际上当你住在冬天更极端、黑暗更极端的地方时，很明显你必须改变自己的行为来适应冬天。很明显，你可能需要在黑暗的季节放慢脚步、多睡觉、多休息，而在夏天的午夜阳光下更加活跃并做更多的事情。很明显，你必须改变你的衣橱和穿衣方式。很明显，你必须改变你照亮房屋的方式。因此，他们发展出了这些行为，我认为这对于拥抱这个季节、顺应这个季节非常有帮助，因为他们在冬天的做法有所不同。我认为我们这些住在中纬度地区的人并没有那种迫切需要改变行为的需求。我们自欺欺人地认为：“哦，是的，我全年都可以保持相同的日程安排。
I can be equally productive year round. I can basically dress the same and I'll just throw on a coat in the winter year round, you know? And I think that really does us a disservice because I think one of the real ways of celebrating winter is leaning into what the season offers and doing things a little bit differently at that time of year than you do in, you know, the spring or the summer or the fall. And that's where I think these lessons from these more extreme climates can really help us. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set
我全年都可以保持同样的生产力。我基本上可以穿同样的衣服，在冬天我只要套上一件大衣就行了，对吧？”我认为这确实对我们没有好处，因为我认为庆祝冬天的一个真正方法是顺应这个季节所提供的一切，在这个季节做一些与你在春天、夏天或秋天做的不太一样的事情。这就是我认为来自这些更极端气候的经验可以真正帮助我们的地方。你的夏天现在从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日优惠开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以使用汉普顿湾 (Hampton Bay) 西格罗夫 (West Grove) 七件套户外餐桌椅套装进行招待
for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price matchmatch. for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止，价格有效期限为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用除外条款。详情请参见 Homedepot.com/pricematch。你曾说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些台阶而已。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app
我们省了多少？够了。够到迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订
and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for this day. It seems like it might be easier to love winter when you live somewhere like Tromso, with the northern lights and sparkling snow and the things that you're talking about that they do to make their lives pleasant. But what if you live somewhere where it's just gray and chilly and drizzly?
最高可省 20%，获得您所期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱，而不是惊喜。住哪里很重要。希尔顿住宿。当你住在像特罗姆瑟这样有极光、闪闪发光的雪以及他们为了让生活变得愉快而做的那些事情的地方时，爱上冬天似乎更容易一些。但是，如果你住在那种只有灰色、寒冷和毛毛雨的地方呢？
I mean, here in the D.C. area, for example, we get more freezing rain than snow, which is really not fun. how can people approach that kind of winter with a positive mindset? Yeah, I think this is a really important question. I do think in some ways Trumpso is the idealized version of winter, you know, like if you watch Disney's Frozen, like that's kind of the land you're living in. There's a lot of beauty and there's a lot of like winter wonder. But I think that a lot of these lessons from Tromso can apply in these other climates. And I know that, you know, like you said, in the D.C. area, in other middle latitude places, like in London or New York, you know, you have a lot of people living with not a lot of snow and a lot of gray, chilly rain. I myself actually live in Amsterdam right now, which does not get snow almost ever anymore, but it's very gray and dark and rainy all winter. And so the question is, what are the lessons we can learn from a more idealized winter place that we can bring wherever.
我的意思是，就拿我们所在的华盛顿特区地区来说，我们下的冻雨比雪多，这真的非常没意思。人们怎么才能以积极的心态面对那种冬天呢？是的，这是一个非常重要的问题。我的确认为在某些方面特罗姆瑟是冬天的理想版本，你知道，就像你看迪斯尼的《冰雪奇缘》一样，那就像是你所生活的那片土地。有很多美景，也有很多冬日的奇观。但我认为特罗姆瑟的许多经验可以应用到这些其他气候中。我知道，正如你所说，在华盛顿特区地区，在其他中纬度地区，比如伦敦或纽约，有很多人生活在没有多少雪、只有大量灰色寒冷雨水的环境中。我自己目前住在阿姆斯特丹，这里几乎再也不会下雪了，但整个冬天都是灰暗、黑暗和多雨的。所以问题是，我们可以从更理想的冬季胜地学到什么经验，并把它带到我们身处的任何地方。
we are. So one is I think making the season special by working with the darkness, right? So lighting candles, embracing low lights, embracing it as a time of year to slow down and do calmer, more peaceful indoor activities and really relishing in the darkness for the opportunities it provides, right? If you drive around your town or city and you enjoy looking at the Christmas this lights. That's a gift of winter darkness, right? You don't get that when it stays light out very late. The ability to eat dinner by candlelight or have an early movie night or have a cozy night indoors reading. All of those things are not just things you can do in the dark, but I would argue things that are better in the dark and that winter gives us the opportunity
无论我们在哪里。首先是通过顺应黑暗来让这个季节变得特别，对吧？所以点燃蜡烛，拥抱微弱的光线，将其拥抱为一年中放慢脚步、进行更平静、更平和的室内活动的时期，并真正为黑暗提供的机遇而感到高兴，对吧？如果你开车穿过你的城镇或城市，你喜欢看着圣诞灯饰。那是冬天的黑暗带来的礼物，对吧？当天黑得很晚时，你不会得到那种体验。伴着烛光吃晚餐、享受早早的电影之夜或在室内舒适地阅读的夜晚。所有这些不仅是你在黑暗中可以做的事情，而且我认为这些是在黑暗中做得更好的事情，并且冬天给了我们真正享受它们的机会。
to really enjoy. I would also say that, you know, every climate has pros and cons, right? So if you live somewhere that is a lot colder, winters tend to be longer and darker, but you get the benefits of snow and sort of that winter beauty. If you live somewhere that tends to be rainier and grayer and chillier, chances are that you live somewhere where actually the days are longer in the winter. And if you really start paying attention to the weather, you might notice more winter sun than you thought you had in your town. A lot of places. A lot of I know that this is true in Amsterdam. I know it's very true in London, have these reputations of like, oh, it rains for six months. It rains all winter long. But if you actually pay attention, that's really not the case that, you know, a lot of these places, even the rainiest months, they might average 13 or 14 rainy days a month. And even on those days, it's not raining the whole day, right? So can you go outside on your lunch break and feel the winter sun on your face on a clear day? you enjoy being outdoors on days that it's not rainy. And then I would also say, you know,
我还想说的是，每种气候都有优点和缺点，对吧？所以如果你住在更寒冷的地方，冬天往往更漫长、更黑暗，但你会获得雪和那种冬日美景的好处。如果你住在更雨水充沛、更灰暗和更寒冷的地方，你很可能会住在冬天白昼更长的地方。如果你真的开始关注天气，你可能会注意到比你想象中更多的冬日阳光。很多地方。我知道阿姆斯特丹是这样的。我也知道伦敦确实如此，这些地方都有这样的名声，比如：“哦，连下六个月的雨。整个冬天都在下雨。”但如果你真的去关注，事实并非如此，你知道，在很多地方，即使是最潮湿的月份，每个月也可能平均只有 13 或 14 个下雨天。即使在那些日子里，也不是下一整天雨，对吧？所以你能在午休时间走到户外，在晴天感受冬日阳光照在脸上的感觉吗？你能在不下雨的日子里享受户外活动吗？然后我还要说，
winter weather can be really fascinating if we let it be, right? So I think, you know, you can lean into the rain being beautiful, the rain being something that enables you to have this cozy time indoors, the rain that is good for activities that maybe get crowded out when it's warm and sunny. So for me, in the summer when it's warm and sunny, I want to be outside. I want to be picnicking. I want to be swimming. I want to be riding my bike. But in the winter, that's my time to read my books. It's my time to be in the pottery studio. It's my time to cook more elaborate meals. It's my time to bake things. And those are things that the season really lends itself to that I look forward to doing on a rainy day. Even my work as a writer, it's really hard for me to write on a warm, sunny day. Like I want to be out. Sorry, right. I don't want to be in front of my computer, you know. But like when I can have my cup of tea and my little desk candle, I can, you know, sort of get into the zone of writing a little bit more easily.
如果我们顺其自然，冬季天气其实可以非常迷人，对吧？所以我想，你可以顺应雨的美丽，雨能让你在室内度过这段舒适的时光，雨有利于那些在温暖晴朗时会被挤满的活动。对我来说，在夏天温暖晴朗的时候，我想在外面。我想野餐。我想游泳。我想骑自行车。但在冬天，这是我读书的时间。这是我在陶艺工作室的时间。这是我烹饪更精致饭菜的时间。这是我烘焙的时间。这些都是这个季节非常适合做的事情，我期待在下雨天做这些事情。甚至我作为作家的工作，在温暖晴朗的日子里对我也真的很难。就像我想出去一样。抱负，对吧。我不想坐在电脑前，你知道。但当我能喝着茶、点着小书桌蜡烛时，我就可以，你知道，更容易进入写作状态。
And so some of it is sort of intentionally romanticizing and leaning into the opportunities of that chilly gray wet weather. I'm going to change this subject to seasonal effective disorder, which I think a lot of our listeners probably know about. I'm just wondering how common is said and how does it differ from simply feeling more tired and less energetic in the winter? Yeah, this is a really important topic because I think there's a lot of confusion around seasonal effective disorder. So seasonal effective disorder is defined in the DSM-5, the diagnostic and statistical manual for diagnosing mental disorders, as a subtype of clinical depression. So in order to be diagnosed with seasonal effective disorder, someone first has to meet the threshold for clinical depression.
所以其中一部分是刻意将这种寒冷、灰色、潮湿的天气浪漫化并顺应它的机遇。我要把话题转到季节性情绪失调（SAD）上，我想我们的很多听众可能对此有所了解。我只是想知道 SAD 有多普遍，它与单纯在冬天感到更疲倦、缺乏活力有什么不同？是的，这是一个非常重要的话题，因为我认为人们对季节性情绪失调存在很多困惑。因此，季节性情绪失调在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM-5，用于诊断精神障碍的诊断和统计手册）中被定义为临床抑郁症的一个亚型。因此，要被诊断患有季节性情绪失调，一个人首先必须达到临床抑郁症的阈值。
And then we can say, okay, is there a seasonally recurring pattern, which most often happens in the winter. You can actually have summer seasonal affective disorder, but it's much rarer. But I think this cultural narrative that winter is depressing is so pervasive, coupled with the idea that a lot of people do feel more tired. the winter, maybe less motivated, maybe less social. And they have this top of mind explanation of, oh, seasonal effective disorder is lots of people are out there saying, yes, I have winter depression, I have seasonal effective disorder who would not say, oh, yeah, I have clinical depression. When in fact, you know, in order to actually meet the criteria, first you would have to say, yes, I have clinical depression. Then you can say I have seasonal effective disorder. There's a lot of disputes
然后我们可以说，好吧，是否存在季节性复发的模式，这种情况最常发生在冬天。你实际上也可能患有夏季季节性情绪失调，但要少得多。但我认为这种认为冬天令人沮丧的文化叙事太普遍了，再加上很多人在冬天确实感觉更疲倦的想法，可能动力不足，可能不那么喜欢社交。并且他们有一个首要的解释：“哦，很多人都在外面说，‘是的，我有冬季抑郁症，我有季节性情绪失调’，而这些人绝不会说‘哦，是的，我有临床抑郁症’。”而实际上，你知道，为了真正符合标准，首先你必须说：“我有临床抑郁症。”然后你才能说我患有季节性情绪失调。这里有很多争议
about seasonal effective disorder and how quote unquote valid it is. It depends a lot on what measure you use. So when it was originally discovered, which it was discovered in the U.S., in the D.C. area in in Maryland, the instrument that was used to diagnose it was called the SPAC, the seasonal pattern assessment questionnaire. And what this measure did is it measured your seasonality and measures, you know, which months do you feel the most tired, the most social, the most energetic? Do you change your eating habits? Do you change your sleeping habits? Do you change your socializing? Which months do you feel the best and worst? And the idea is that if you have really extreme seasonality, then you have winter depression. So if you say, oh, I sleep a lot more, I eat a lot more,
关于季节性情绪失调以及它到底有多大程度的所谓“有效性”。这很大程度上取决于你使用什么测量标准。因此，当它最初在美国华盛顿特区地区的马里兰州被发现时，用于诊断它的仪器被称为 SPAC（季节模式评估问卷）。这项测量所做的是它测量你的季节性并测量，你知道，你在哪几个月感觉最累、最合群、最有活力？你改变饮食习惯了吗？你改变睡眠习惯了吗？你改变社交方式了吗？你在哪几个月感觉最好和最差？其核心思想是，如果你有非常极端的季节性，那么你就有冬季抑郁症。所以如果你说，“哦，我在冬天睡得更多、吃得更多，
I'm a lot less social in the winter, then you could be diagnosed with seasonal affective disorder. And studies that use this criteria tend to find higher rates of seasonal effective disorder. But in my view, and I think in a lot of view of psychologists, even those who now study sad, this doesn't quite capture depression specifically, right? You could actually have pretty extreme seasonality and it could be really healthy and adaptive. And this is what I saw in trousseau, right? people are changing their eating and sleeping and socializing habits, but it's not bothersome to them. They don't view it as a bad thing. They view it as living in tune with nature. And so now a lot of
我的社交活动要少得多”，那么你可能会被诊断患有季节性情绪失调。使用这一标准的研究往往会发现季节性情绪失调的发病率更高。但在我看来，我认为在许多心理学家的眼中，甚至在那些现在研究 SAD 的人看来，这并没有完全捕捉到抑郁症的具体特征，对吧？你实际上可以拥有相当极端的季节性，而且它可能是非常健康和适应性的。这就是我在特罗姆瑟看到的情况，对吧？人们在改变他们的饮食、睡眠和社交习惯，但这并没有困扰他们。他们不认为这是一件坏事。他们认为这是与大自然和谐共处。所以现在很多
researchers prefer to use the more rigorous standard of first screening for clinical depression and then looking for the seasonal pattern. And if you do that, we actually find much lower rates of seasonal effective disorder. And there's a lot of evidence that outside of the U.S. in places with very long harsh winters, so in Tromso, in the Netherlands, in Iceland, they find very low rates of seasonal effective disorder or no evidence of this seasonal pattern of depression. So a lot of people have sort of been questioning this idea of seasonal effective disorder. Is it useful? Do we want to look for you know, how common is it really? So it's really hard to give an exact prevalence. I would say, if you have, if you feel that you have clinical depression and you do feel that you have this
研究人员倾向于使用更严格的标准，即首先筛查临床抑郁症，然后寻找季节性模式。如果你这样做，我们实际上会发现季节性情绪失调的发病率要低得多。有大量证据表明，在美国以外拥有漫长严寒冬天的地区——例如在特罗姆瑟、荷兰、冰岛——他们发现季节性情绪失调的发病率非常低，或者没有这种抑郁季节性模式的证据。因此，许多人一直在质疑季节性情绪失调这个概念。它有用吗？我们想寻找，你知道，它到底有多普遍？所以很难给出一个确切的患病率。我想说，如果你有，如果你觉得你患有临床抑郁症，并且你确实觉得你有这种
seasonal pattern, that it's a good opportunity to seek treatment for depression as you would at any other time of year. For most people, however, I think what's really important to acknowledge is that we are affected by winter and people are feeling that, right? You're feeling the impact of winter on your energy, on your mood, on your appetite, on how much you sleep. And the problem, I think, comes with pathologizing that, with saying that's bad, right? I have friends who know what I study, who, you know, the second or third week of November after the clock's change, will be like, oh, I've been so tired. I just don't know what's wrong with me. And I'm like, hello, like, the days are shortening. You know, we've lost an hour in the evenings. Like, it's,
季节性模式，这是一个很好的机会，可以像一年中的任何其他时间一样去寻求抑郁症治疗。然而，对大多数人来说，我认为真正重要的是承认我们受到冬天的影响，人们确实有这种感觉，对吧？你正在感受到冬天对你的精力、心情、食欲以及睡眠时间的影响。我认为，问题在于将这种现象病理化，说这是不好的，对吧。我有一些朋友知道我的研究领域，他们会在时钟拨回后的十一月第二周或第三周说：“哦，我太累了。我真不知道自己怎么了。”而我会说：“嗨，白天变短了。
normal to be more tired. And if you look at every other living thing on earth, plant or animal, they all change their behavior in winter. They almost all are resting more, sleeping more in the winter. And so I think, in my view, the best way to address the winter blues of this feeling that the season really does impact us is to say, okay, how can I work with these feelings? How can I say, yes, I am more tired in the winter. I sleep more in the winter. That's okay. Let me make sense. space for that, let me ease up on maybe my commitments or how much I socialize or what kind of activities I pursue and use winter as an opportunity to slow down rather than saying, oh, there's something wrong with me. I must be depressed if I'm more tired in the winter.
我们在晚上的时间少了一个小时。所以，更疲倦是正常的。”如果你看看地球上的每一个其他生物，无论是植物还是动物，它们都会在冬天改变自己的行为。它们几乎都在冬天更多地休息、更多地睡眠。因此，在我看来，解决冬季郁闷情绪或这种季节确实对我们产生影响的感觉的最好方法是说：“好吧，我如何才能顺应这些感受？我如何才能说，是的，我在冬天更累。我在冬天睡得更多。没关系。让我为此留出空间，让我稍微放松一下我的承诺、我的社交活动或我所追求的活动种类，把冬天当作一个放慢脚步的机会，而不是说，‘哦，我一定有什么问题。如果我在冬天更累，我一定抑郁了。’”
We can say this is normal, this is healthy, this is adaptive. And this is one of these things that I actually think practicing this in the winter is really powerful because we'll all have times when we're forced to slow down like it or not, right? You get sick. You have to have surgery. You're burnt out. You're grieving. You've given birth. Whatever it is, there's going to be times in our life where we're forced to sort of pump the brakes and rest more and prioritize restoration. And I think when we get in the habit of practicing that seasonally, maybe that can become a little bit easier for us when we have to do this at other times of life. Do you think that climate change is a how people feel about winter and really how people emotionally react to it.
我们可以说这是正常的，健康的，也是适应性的。我认为在冬天练习这一点真的非常有力，因为我们都会遇到不得不放慢脚步的时候，不管愿意与否，对吧？你生病了。你需要做手术。你筋疲力尽。你在悲伤。你刚生完孩子。无论是什么，我们的生活中总会有一些时刻，我们被迫踩下刹车，多休息，把恢复精力放在首位。我认为，当我们习惯于季节性地练习这一点时，也许当我们需要在生活的其他时期这样做时，它会变得对我们来说更容易一些。你认为气候变化是人们对冬天的看法以及人们对冬天的情感反应的一个因素吗？
I do. I do. I mean, you know, you can't write and talk and think about winter without writing and talking and thinking about climate change, especially given my own personal ties to the Arctic. You know, I'm seeing people that I know living in Tromsa and even north of Tromsa and Svalbard, an island halfway between Northern Nori and the North Pole, who are experiencing very very. different winters because they're feeling the climate change in their season. You know, I started writing about this topic 10 years ago. And then almost no one was asking me how to survive the heat and the summers. And now I'm getting more and more people saying, forget how to winter. How do I deal with these brutally hot summers? And also 10 years ago, no one was asking me what there is to lose when we lose winter. And now I'm getting a lot more questions about what do we lose when we lose the season of winter? And I think there's a lot more people living in places,
确实如此。我是说，你知道的，你不可能在不谈论、不思考气候变化的情况下，去书写、谈论和思考冬天，尤其是考虑到我与北极的个人联系。你知道的，我看到我认识的人住在特罗姆瑟，甚至特罗姆瑟以北以及斯瓦尔巴群岛（位于挪威北部和北极点之间的一个岛屿），他们正在经历非常非常不同的冬天，因为他们在自己的季节里感受到了气候变化。你知道的，我十年前开始写这个话题。那时几乎没有人问我如何熬过炎热的夏天。现在越来越多的人对我说，别管怎么过冬了，我该如何应对这些残酷炎热的夏天？而且在十年前，也没有人问我，当我们失去冬天时，我们会失去什么。现在我收到了更多关于“当我们失去冬季这个季节时，我们会失去什么”的问题，我认为有更多的人住在这些地方，
right, like the D.C. area, like Amsterdam, that are on the cusp where the difference of a few degrees in winter means the difference between snow in the winter, which reflects the light and opens up a whole host of activities that you can do in the winter and a long, rainy gray winter, like the one that we were talking about earlier. And so I think people are feeling more and more that winter is in danger and that winter is precious. And I think we're also starting to see the ways that protecting winter protects other things that we love. So for example, in researching the book, I learned all about the process of vernalization, which is plants that need a certain number of chill hours in order to bloom successfully in the spring. So a lot of nuts and fruits, things like peaches, require a certain
对吧，比如华盛顿特区地区、阿姆斯特丹，它们正处于临界点，冬天温度相差几度，就意味着冬天是否有雪的区别。雪可以反射光线，并开启你在冬天可以进行的各种活动，而如果没有雪，就会像我们之前谈到的那样，是一个漫长、阴雨连绵、灰暗的冬天。因此，我认为人们越来越感觉得到冬天处于危险之中，冬天是珍贵的。我想我们也开始看到，保护冬天也就是保护我们热爱的其他事物。例如，在研究这本书的过程中，我了解到了春化过程的所有知识，这就是植物需要一定数量的低温冷激小时数，才能在春天成功开花。所以许多坚果和水果，比如桃子，需要一定
number of cold hours in order to bloom successfully. And when winter ends too early, that whole process is in danger. So I believe it was the 2022-2020 season. It was very warm in Georgia and the southern U.S. The peaches started developing early. And then there was a freeze at a normal time, but the peaches had already developed, and so the peaches froze, and they were all destroyed, and it destroyed the peach crop. And actually, that whole area of Georgia was declared a natural disaster zone because it had such a big impact on the crop. And so even things that we think of as enjoying in summer, like our favorite stone fruits,
数量的低温小时数才能成功开花。当冬天结束得太早时，整个过程就会面临危险。所以我想那是2022-2020（应为2020-2022）年的季节。佐治亚州和美国南部非常温暖。桃子开始提前发育。然后在正常的时间发生了一场寒潮，但桃子已经长出来了，所以桃子被冻住了，全都被毁了，这摧毁了桃子的收成。事实上，佐治亚州的整个地区都被宣布为自然灾害区，因为它对农作物产生了如此大的影响。因此，甚至连那些我们认为在夏天才能享受的东西，比如我们最喜欢的水果，
right, rely on winter to exist. And there's all of these kinds of interdependent things where when we don't have the proper freeze cycles. When we don't have the proper cold in the winter, it puts a lot of things in danger. And I think more and more people are starting to notice that. And I think the people who love winter are the most motivated to protect it. So I'm a member of the Science Alliance for an organization called Protect Our Winters, which was founded by Jeremy Jones, who is a pro snowboarder, as he started noticing that more and more, there weren't as many places for him to go snowboard. or the snowboarding season was much shorter. And all around the country and all around the world,
对吧，都要依靠冬天才能存在。所有这些都是相互依存的，当我们没有适当的冰冻周期时，当我们冬天没有适当的寒冷时，它会把很多东西置于危险之中。我认为越来越多的人开始注意到这一点。而且我认为热爱冬天的人最有动力去保护它。所以我是“保护我们的冬天”组织科学联盟的成员，该组织由职业单板滑雪运动员杰里米·琼斯创立，因为他开始注意到，越来越多适合他去滑雪的地方没有了，或者滑雪季节短得多了。在全国各地和世界各地，
there's people who love winter recreation, who love winter sports, who are really motivated to protect the season. And so I think this idea of appreciating winter, I hope, can help inspire more people to want to take action on climate change, to protect the winter, to protect the seasons to protect the things that winter provides us so that we can have all of these opportunities, you know, for decades to come. When you were writing this book, you traveled to many cold weather places around the world to learn more about how other people do winter. Did you discover any other favorite winter traditions in addition to what the Norwegians do? Who else does winter really well? There's so many. I mean, one of the things I learned traveling around doing research,
都有热爱冬季娱乐、热爱冬季运动的人，他们非常有动力去保护这个季节。所以我想这个欣赏冬天的想法，我希望能够帮助激励更多的人想要对气候变化采取行动，保护冬天，保护这些季节，保护冬天提供给我们的东西，这样我们在未来的几十年里就能拥有所有这些机会。当你写这本书的时候，你去了世界上许多寒冷的地方，以了解其他人是如何过冬的。除了挪威人的做法，你还发现了其他喜欢的冬季传统吗？还有谁把冬天过得很好？有很多。我是说，我在四处旅行做研究的过程中学到的事情之一，
search for this book is that every culture, I think, has ways of celebrating and appreciating winter. If only you look for them. So, for example, I went to the Outer Hebrides off the coast of Scotland because there, they have a really long, dark, wet, windy winter, but they don't get snow. And so I really wanted to say, okay, what do people do in a climate like that? And they do a lot of community gatherings. So the Gaelic word is called Kaley. It's Kaley culture. And this idea of coming together for communal events, dinners, celebrations, gathering around, telling stories, sitting by the fire, usually drinking whiskey, you know, is really essential for surviving these long, dark nights. I was also really interested in cultures and how they seek warmth in the winter. Right. So in Finland,
为了这本书，我发现我认为每种文化都有庆祝和欣赏冬天的独特方式。只要你去寻找它们。例如，我去了苏格兰海岸外的外赫布里底群岛，因为那里有一个非常漫长、黑暗、潮湿、多风的冬天，但不会下雪。所以我真的很想说，好吧，人们在这样的气候下会做什么？他们会举行很多社区聚会。所以盖尔语单词叫 Kaley。这就是 Kaley 文化。这种为集体活动、晚宴、庆祝活动聚在一起的想法，围坐在一起，讲故事，坐在火炉旁，通常喝着威士忌，你知道的，对于度过这些漫长黑暗的夜晚是至关重要的。我也对各种文化以及它们如何在冬天寻求温暖很感兴趣。对吧。所以在芬兰，
sauna is, you know, a very sacred part of the culture. You know, in Iceland where they have geothermal energy, they go, they have geothermal pools all over the country. In Japan, likewise, they also have geothermal baths and they do a lot of hot water bathing. And one thing that I found really interesting that I didn't know before I started researching the book was that a lot of these things that people have been doing for thousands of years, right? Like going to the onset in Japan, we're going to the sauna in Finland, there's a whole host of recent research showing the health benefits of these activities and showing that they're protective against things like heart attack and Alzheimer's disease and they can treat arthritis and migraines and skin conditions.
桑拿是（你知道的）文化中非常神圣的一部分。你知道的，在冰岛，他们有地热能，他们去那里，全国各地都有地热温泉。在日本，同样地，他们也有地热浴，并且他们做很多热水浴。我发现了一件非常有趣的事情，在开始研究这本书之前我并不知道，那就是人们几千年来一直在做的很多事情，对吧？就像去日本的温泉，或者去芬兰的桑拿，最近有很多研究表明这些活动对健康有益，并表明它们可以防止心脏病发作和阿尔茨海默病等疾病，还可以治疗关节炎、偏头痛和皮肤病。
I mean, in Finland, they've called the sauna the poor man's pharmacy and the research is really corroborating that. And so this idea that activities we can. can enjoy in the winter, that feel really special in the winter, and that also feel good physically and emotionally are also very health promoting, I think is really powerful. I think, you know, sometimes we have this view of like, if it's, if it doesn't hurt, it's not healthy, you know, if it's not, if it's not punishment, it's not health promoting. But I think in winter, there's a lot of ways to sink physical pleasure and health, whether that's just taking a hot bath or going to the sauna or, you know, slowing down and drinking a cup of tea.
我是说，在芬兰，他们把桑拿称为穷人的药房，研究确实证实了这一点。因此，这种我们可以在冬天享受的活动的想法，在冬天感觉非常特别，而且在身体和情感上也感觉很好，同时也非常促进健康，我认为这真的很有力量。我认为，你知道，有时我们有这样一种观点，即“如果不疼，就不健康”，你知道的，如果它不是一种惩罚，它就不是促进健康的。但我认为在冬天，有很多方法可以将身体的快乐和健康结合起来，无论是洗个热水澡，还是去蒸桑拿，或者，你知道的，慢下来喝一杯茶。
I think there's a lot of evidence growing that these things are really good for us and are life extending, even as they can feel sort of life-giving on these dark days of the season. So just to wrap up, are you still doing research in this area? What else are you working on now? So I am still doing research in one sense of the word. You know, I'm not doing a lot of academic research on this currently, but as I write and talk and speak about this, there's so much to learn from other cultures and a lot to explore. And I would love to sort of come back to this idea of researching winter mindset and winter well-being. I'm mostly focused on psychology communication right now.
我认为有越来越多的证据表明这些对我们真的很好，并且可以延长寿命，正如它们在这个季节黑暗的日子里能让我们感到重焕生机一样。所以总结一下，你还在这个领域做研究吗？你现在还在忙些什么？从某种意义上说，我仍然在做研究。你知道的，我目前没有在这个领域做很多学术研究，但是当我写作、谈论和讨论这个时，有很多东西可以向其他文化学习，也有很多东西需要探索。我很乐意回到研究冬季心态和冬季幸福感的这个想法上来。我目前主要专注于心理学传播。
So this kind of writing and speaking and teaching. But I have some ongoing collaborations with some of my former lab members from the Stanford Mind and Body Lab. There's some very exciting work coming out of King's College in London, a colleague of mine, Lauren Heathcote, who is working on helping survivors of childhood cancer to adopt more useful mindsets about their bodies and their health and how can we help these kids monitor their bodies and monitor their health symptoms in ways that are less threatening and less anxiety-inducing. And so I think, I hope that winter mindset will be an entryway for, your listeners to start diving into all of the ways that mindset can influence our health and
所以这种写作、演讲和教学。但我与我在斯坦福身心实验室的一些前实验室成员有一些正在进行的合作。伦敦国王学院正在开展一些非常激动人心的工作，我的同事劳伦·希思科特（Lauren Heathcote）正在致力于帮助儿童癌症幸存者对自己的身体和健康采取更有用的心态，以及我们如何能够帮助这些孩子们以一种威胁较小、焦虑感较低的方式监测自己的身体和健康症状。所以我想，我希望冬季心态能成为你的听众开始深入了解心态如何影响我们的健康和幸福的所有方式的一个入口，
well-being. And there's a lot of really exciting research happening in this area now. And I think we're just at the very beginning of understanding the impact of mindset, the mechanisms of mindset, and really the potential of mindset to improve our lives in many different ways. Well, Dr. Leibowitz, want to thank you for joining me today. This has been great. This was so wonderful. Thanks for your thoughtful questions. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
现在这个领域有很多非常令人兴奋的研究。我认为我们才刚刚开始了解心态的影响、心态的机制，以及心态真正有潜力以许多不同的方式改善我们的生活。好的，莱博维茨博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。这太棒了。这太美妙了。谢谢你深思熟虑的问题。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学说话》节目。如果您喜欢您听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological. Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order.
《心理学说话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听美国心理学会节目。我是金·米尔斯。放松身心，让拉尔夫配送本周帮您包办杂货采购。我们只挑选最新鲜的商品，然后核对您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们会把它们全部打包并在短短 30 分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的东西。新鲜杂货，随您心意，尽在拉尔夫配送与自提。现在，您的首次配送或自提订单即可节省 20 美元。
Ralphs, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拉尔夫，为每个人保鲜。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。